si on veut être dans les délais merci
d'avoir de votre
venue au Sénat et d'avoir accepté cette
audition qui
représente toujours présenté aujourd'hui
l'Union des industries des entreprises
de l'eau
et donc dans le cadre de notre mission
sur la gestion durable de l'eau qui
était demandé par le groupe socialiste
nous avons fait une mission
transpartizane puisque c'est l'habitude
de la maison avec notre apporteur
Hervé gilet qui est sénateur de Gironde
et moi-même donc les sénateurs du Cher
en tant que président
et cette audition donc fait l'objet de
la compte-rendu officiel et vous aurez
les éléments bien évidemment et le
rapport quand on leur a terminé en
juillet puisqu'on a prévu de le déposer
début juillet
et on a auditionné beaucoup de
d'organismes qui s'occupe de l'eau
depuis le mois de février et l'objectif
c'est de savoir un peu comment vous
voyez les choses de votre côté d'être à
votre écoute pour savoir en tant que
entreprise
pour les adductions d'eau certainement
les tout ce qui concerne les pompages
les vous avez certainement un peu une
votre vision d'entrepreneur et
d'entreprise et donc on est intéressé
pour savoir un petit peu avec les
questions qui que vous avez reçues
d'ailleurs
donc notre rapporteur va vous passer à
la question
[Rires]
approfondir quelques sujets quelques
sujets un peu plus stratégique peut-être
si vous le si vous le voulez bien
et au stade nous en sommes de la mission
d'information
les traits un petit peu saillants les
sujets un peu saillants qui se posent
effectivement aujourd'hui
alors tout d'abord l'affirmation de la
gestion par bassin versant bien sûr mais
ça suppose aujourd'hui l'affirmation
d'un modèle de données en termes de
connaissances de la ressource et des
consommations ce qui n'est pas encore
suffisamment établi malgré tout quand on
y regarde d'un peu plus près
voir de quelle manière ensuite les
politiques nationales et territoriales
s'articule autour de ces gouvernances de
bassins comment elle les décline à la
fois au niveau des régions des
départements sur lesquels il conviendra
de reclarifier leur position notamment
sur l'appui d'ingénierie locale
puisqu'ils sont toujours un peu attendus
sur ces sujets là et il y a une petite
une clarification à avoir la montée en
connaissance et en prospective de
l'ensemble des maîtrises d'ouvrages
notamment sur les syndicats d'eau et
d'assainissement puisque c'est très
hétérogène dans les capacités
d'anticipation de projection de
connaissances des patrimoines de
diagnostics il y a des écarts quand même
très importants aujourd'hui il faut
absolument les corriger voire de quelle
manière l'ensemble des acteurs peuvent
s'engager sous forme de contrat
d'engagement réciproque qui permettrait
de d'avoir des trajectoires de sobriété
et en même temps de partager
la vision et la Rép artition de la
ressource
ce qui suppose aussi
d'améliorer les process à tous les
niveaux industriels plus
particulièrement aussi agricoles et donc
la nécessité d'accompagner l'évolution
de ces modèles pour qu'il s'adapte au
mieux dans des conditions acceptables au
niveau concurrentiel une meilleure
organisation donc ce cas de figure aussi
de la recherche qu'elle soit
fondamentale appliquée
sachant qu'en l'occurrence pour ce qui
vous concerne vous avez des centres de
recherche et développement assez
important au niveau de vos adhérents
donc c'est aussi un sujet en soi
aujourd'hui pour voir comment ça
atterrit aussi sur les sur les
territoires
et puis il y aura sans doute sans doute
aussi une affirmation d'une meilleure
intégration de la gestion de l'eau dans
les documents d'urbanisme aujourd'hui et
avoir une vision plus claire en
planification que ce soit au niveau des
stradettes des Scotts et des pays
notamment sur le pluvial aujourd'hui il
y a des nouveaux enjeux qui apparaissent
sur une gestion plus stratégique du
pluviale
et il y aura sans doute des éléments que
l'on va essayer de creuser autour de du
rapport pour vous donner quelques
tressaillants voilà qui sont travaillés
à répondre à nos interrogations très
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur merci de nous accueillir pour
cette mission pour répondre à votre à
vos questions et que nous permet de
s'exprimer voilà pour répondre à ces
grands sujets sur le domaine de l'eau
donc ne représentons les les entreprises
qui participent à l'acte de construire
et de fabriquer les équipements
nécessaires au traitement d'eau de
manière générale donc depuis le pompage
jusqu'au traitement des eaux avant le
rejet en rivière mais en passant aussi
par donc le captage le stockage le la
production d'eau potable l'adduction
d'eau potable le traitement des eaux
usées la réutilisation des eaux usées
traitées sujet dont on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui mais aussi les fabrication
des cuves des équipements tels que les
canalisations de de nécessaire au
transport de l'eau qui représente
une infrastructure très importante au
bord de la nation
et donc voilà c'est tout cet ensemble
d'acteurs économiques qui sont regroupés
au teint au sein de l'Union des
industries à de l'eau et l'environnement
qui est un des syndicats de spécialités
de la Fédération nationale des tropiques
que vous continuez évidemment qui
regroupe plus de 8000 entreprises
et qui agit sur tous les territoires au
travers de ces fédérations régionales de
travaux publics mais aussi ces syndicats
de spécialités ces fédérations
spécialités dont l'uyeux qui est celle
qui intervient sur l'eau aux côtés d'une
autre fédération qui pèse à peu près le
même point économique qui est celle des
canalisateurs donc lui c'est 4 milliards
d'euros d'activités à peu près dont 3
milliards en France un milliard donc à
l'international à l'export par an
qui sont réalisés par ces 200
entreprises qui adhèrent en fonction de
leur spécialité à différents syndicats
sous syndicat de lui
les canalisateurs
ont une activité économique qui est à
peu près du même ordre de grandeur
légèrement supérieur de 5 à 6 milliards
d'euros suivant les suivant les années
donc voilà qui qui nous sommes c'est à
dire que nous sommes pas opérateurs nous
sommes pas distributeurs nous nous
construisons et nous entretenons les
infrastructures destinées à l'eau et
dans ce cadre-là d'ailleurs nous nous
sommes interrogés à depuis à depuis
quelques années et en particulier à au
travers de deux études qui ont été
faites en 2017 et plus récemment 2022
sur l'état du patrimoine de ces
infrastructeurs ces infrastructures que
l'on connaît mal parce que la plupart
des hôtels sont enterrées on les voit
pas
mais on a fait ce travail de recensement
et puis un autre travail aussi de savoir
quel était la situation patrimoniale de
ces interrupteurs
au niveau des syndicats il y en a
beaucoup
qui sont mauvaises connaissances de leur
patrimoine donc se recensement il a
forcément ses limites
alors sinon vous touchez du doigt un
enjeu important vous avez commencé à
parler d'inventer l'introduction de la
donnée et en effet de l'absence de
certaines données et je vous rejoins là
dessus et je m'en inquiète d'autant plus
que entre notre étude de 2017 et de 2022
on a vu que la donnée était en train de
s'appauvrir la qualité de la donnée la
précision de la donnée notre étude
menée par l'UE avec donc l'économiste
Maria Salvetti repose que sur des
données publiques des données qui sont
publiées par les différents
ministères service CGDD cegdd etc est-ce
que l'on remarque c'est que les jeux de
données que nous avions en 2017 n'ont
pas été réactualisés avec le même niveau
de détail
sur la période 2017-2022 pour pour que
l'on déshabille notre nouvelle notre
actualisation de cette étude
et donc il y a moins de précision sur
la différence ce qui est ce qui fléchait
sur le potable sur l'assainissement des
fois c'est regroupé sur le
fonctionnement et sur l'investissement
donc ce sont des chiffres qui sont qui
sont d'une qualité moins précise et qui
nous permettent d'aller moins dans le la
vérification du détail donc
effectivement il y a un travail de
réconciliation de ces données en se
basant aussi sur les jeux de données
précédentes possibles de voir un petit
peu que la qualité la situation
précédente et essayer d'imaginer comment
elle a pu évoluer donc c'est un point
d'attention ça interroge un cadre
normatif également
vous pouvez développer votre question
sur le cadre de l'information de
production de données pour avoir un
système qui soit le plus cohérent
possible on peut très bien à ce
moment-là normer et faire en sorte que
les remonter l'information soit vraiment
stabilisée et que à la fois
de telle manière avoir un cadre
méthodologique un cadre normé de
remonter l'information absolument alors
il y a un cadre qui est
un cadre qui existe à travers du système
qui est le portail sur lequel le
collectivités sont invités à fournir à
fournir les chiffres
forcer de constater que
elles ont ils ont des difficultés à le
remplir environ en temps et en heure et
parfois leur empire tout court donc il y
a il y a beaucoup d'inconnus en effet
sur la précision de notamment de l'état
du patrimoine et l'état des niveaux de
connaissances du patrimoine et c'est un
vrai questionnant parce que c'est le
début de ce qu'on appelle donc la
gestion patrimoniale c'est de connaître
son patrimoine et forcer de constater
que c'est souvent il n'y a pas de
réponse et donc on peut imaginer qu'à
partir du moment où il y a pas de
réponse c'est qu'il le patrimoine n'est
pas connu et donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
de préoccupation je vous rejoins
complètement monsieur le rapporteur
donc notre étude elle est basée sur les
chiffres de données officielles données
publiques c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas
les produits en nous-mêmes de vos
chiffres on a pris que les données
officielles et ces données officielles
on les a synthétisés recroiser pour en
faire une vision patrimoniale ça c'est
la le
tout le sens de la démarche que l'on a
fait comment on le ferait pour une
entreprise d'essayer de savoir à la télé
son actif quel est son passif mais aussi
qu'elles sont ces flux c'est flux
d'investissement et donc cette vision à
la fois économique
d'un point de vue bilaniel et d'un point
de vue flux d'investissement d'une part
et d'autre part les informations
notamment celles de 6 PA sur le niveau
de performance et le niveau d’état des
infrastructures donc des données qui
sont plus physiques et performantiel
d'un point de vue destination de
l'ouvrage
donc c'est c'est ce qui nous c'est ce
qui nous anime et de ce point de vue là
donc nous sommes des observateurs
économiques de la politique nationale de
l'eau
et c'est vraiment la posture que nous
aurons aujourd'hui c'est à dire cette
observateur économique qui regarde
comment la politique de l'eau
agit sur l'investissement et le
renouvellement de ces infrastructures
voire le l'investissement dans des
domaines comme les eaux pluviales
sur lequel vous avez aussi un point de
question donc les produits déjà des
premières orientations ou des
conclusions que vous pouvez communiquer
cette observatoire
l'étude qui a été menée oui elle arrive
à des conclusions c'est-à-dire que en
2000 en 2017 nous avions estimé le
sous-investissement par rapport au
vieillissement des infrastructures et la
nécessité de l'amortissement qu'on
pensait l'amortissement du
vieillissement des infrastructures par
du nouvel investissement
et on était arrivé à un
sous-investissement qui était de l'ordre
de 3 milliards d'euros
en 2022 nous arrivons à un chiffre de
4,6 milliards et qui contient 3 secteurs
le renouvellement dans les sur le petit
cycle de l'eau sur les infrastructures
d'eau potable d'assainissement pour 3
milliards de sous-investissement
toujours un milliard de
sous-investissements sur la partie
pluviale
et puis on a aussi
identifié le coût qui serait nécessaire
pour traiter les micropollutions avec
les micropollutions on en parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui il y a une
attention toute particulière assez à ce
qu'on appelle les polluants et qu'on
appelait polluants émergents on les
appelle maintenant polluant persistant
voire polluant éternel quand on adresse
certaines familles de polluants et donc
on a essayé d'anticiper les coûts
nécessaires pour traiter ces nouveaux
polluants ces nouvelles molécules
de la discussion c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet très très important puisque
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'on perd à peu
près un milliard de mètres cubes d'eau
potable par an à travers les
canalisations
fuyards et c'est vrai que la priorité
des priorités devraient aujourd'hui être
de faire procéder à la rénovation de
canalisation qui ont parfois 40 50 60
ans
et on a plus de fuite d'ailleurs en
milieu rural comme milieu urbain parce
que on a parfois des kilomètres de
canalisations pour aller
porter l'eau à 3 ou 4 maisons donc c'est
c'est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui les
agences de l'eau nous disent qu'il
faudrait 2 milliards d'euros
d'investissement par an je sais pas
pendant combien de temps il faudrait le
faire pour arriver à
vraiment remettre à niveau toutes les
canalisations
vous vous nous parlez de de 3 milliards
mais là vous êtes plutôt sur l'ensemble
des investissements moi je vous parle
d'uniquement parce que c'est un vrai
sujet pour les collectivités aujourd'hui
on manque de financement pour pouvoir
faire tous les travaux donc si c'est 2
milliards pendant combien d'années il
faudrait investir pour arriver à être un
niveau et aujourd'hui à combien on est
par exemple pour tout ce qui est
adduction d'eau potable parce que c'est
ça c'est intéressant de savoir combien
on investit aujourd'hui pour savoir
quelle est la marge qu'il faut alors sur
laquelle il faut progresser
dans notre étude et nous vous gênerons
l'étude complète et aussi la synthèse de
cette étude nous nous estimons que les
besoins en renouvellement sur
la partie eau potable
ce sont de 2,7 milliards d'euros par an
pour les branchements donc ça c'est
en moyenne pourquoi parce que
alors je vais vous donner le détail
consolidé j'ai pas tous les chiffres
détaillés mais je vais vous donner donc
on a agrégé
les réseaux d'eau potable les
branchements entre le domicile et le
réseau qui représente un milliard de
sous de besoins en renouvellement les
réservoirs les usines les forages quand
on se dit tout ça on dit pour entretenir
un patrimoine
qui a de manière globale le patrimoine
de l'eau c'est 500 milliards d'actifs à
peu près en valeur 9 il faudrait 4,4
milliards sur cette partie eau potable
il faudrait 5 milliards sur la partie
assainissement est-ce qu'on constate
c'est que sur la dernière période c'est
pas 4,4 milliards qu'on a investi sur la
partie eau potable mais uniquement 2,6
milliards donc on est sur un
sous-investissement de 1,8 milliards sur
la partie eau potable
majoritairement sur les canalisations
puisque c'est un des actifs le plus le
plus lourd mais il y a aussi des usines
il y a aussi donc je parle canalisation
c'est canalisations et branchements mais
il y a aussi des usines les ouvrages
réservoirs
et les forages et on y reviendra sur les
forages parce qu'il y a une vraie
question sur sur l'abandon les forages
qui nous préoccupe aussi
rapidement parce que sur les forages
l'orientation d'augmenter
de protection des forages
on voit pas comment nous ne pourrions
pas aller dans cette dimension là ce qui
suppose derrière bien sûr avoir les bons
principes de financement pour service
rendu par rapport pour créer les
conditions de protection mais on voit
que aujourd'hui ça évolue d'une manière
assez favorable même si parfois c'est
parfois conflictuel ou autre mais on
arrive à trouver quand même des
solutions peut-être que vous avez
d'ailleurs des propositions à faire dans
ce cas là et voilà
alors sur les forages quand on regarde
de manière rétrospective sur les trois
dernières décennies
on a perdu 12.500 forages en France
pour 38000 forage actif donc 12500 c'est
quand même un tiers enfin de des Forges
actifs ou si on prend sur la les
chiffres ça veut dire un quart du
patrimoine de forage a été abandonné
abandonné soit pour des raisons de
pollution
principalement et un peu pour des
raisons économiques parfois mais tu es
quand même le chiffre est préoccupant de
se dire voilà on est à on a ce à
ce nombre d'abandons de plusieurs
milliers sur une durée certes assez
longue et c'est là que la donnée
qu'elle vous faisiez allusion monsieur
le rapporteur elle est elle est
importante savoir suivie pour voir
effectivement si les politiques de
protection des captages qui ont été mis
en oeuvre portent réellement leurs
fruits ce qui est sûr c'est que
on retrouve encore à décontaminations
avec des molécules qui ont pourtant été
interdites sur le marché depuis un
certain nombre d'années et donc on a un
effet retard aussi de d'une activité
humaine d'une activité contrario quand
il y a un périmètre de protection que
les mesures ont été cohérentes on voit
aussi des évolutions si positives
exactement et donc c'est d'où
l'importance d'avoir de la donner
suffisamment précise pour pouvoir
prendre les signaux positifs renforcer
ces les mesures qui ont permis d'arriver
à ça et puis il y a le cas échéant on va
remettre en question certaines
décisions sur les périmètres de captage
pour les rendre encore plus à encore
plus
par rapport à l'évaluation vous faisiez
donc voilà au niveau à la fois du
patrimoine donc sur l'évolution du
patrimoine et pour en revenir aux
chiffres à la question de monsieur le
Président sur les deux milliards des
agences oui on va retourner à peu près
sur sur le même ordre de grandeur sur la
partie canalisation
de sous-investissement et donc
d'ailleurs si on le remet en perspective
avec les chiffres je vous ai donné sur
l'activité à la fois des canalisations
des poseurs de canalisation et puis des
fabricants de de
d'équipements c'est un chiffre qui est
significatif et c'est ainsi que nous qui
nous interpellent c'est-à-dire que on se
dit si on doit faire des milliards
d'euros de plus sur les canalisations
plus à
encore un milliard sur le reste des
infrastructures et un milliard enfin les
infrastructures du petit cycle et un
milliard sur la partie plus ça veut dire
que par rapport à notre activité
au sein de lui qui représente 4
milliards par an plus celle des
canalisateurs il y a une partie qui est
qui est en chevauchement puisque
on vend au canalisateur une partie de
chiffre d'affaires mais
ça voudrait dire que on va augmenter le
niveau d'investissement en France
2 environ 6 milliards à 10 milliards si
on voulait entretenir le patrimoine et
donc ce passage de 6 milliards à 10
milliards c'est un changement d'échelle
à l'échelle industrielle ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir qu'on soit capable de
produire en France
les équipements les équipements
nécessaires à se renouvellement que l'on
forme les équipes de pose que l'on forme
les équipes de travaux que l'on forme
les équipes de maîtrise d'oeuvre
et de maîtrise d'ouvrage et c'est un
autre point que vous avez aborder votre
introduction pour faire ça et c'est un
changement énorme c'est 4 milliards
supplémentaires qu'on a quand on évalue
c'est à c'est pas loin d'un doublement
mais c'est
une montée progressive
on dit mais donnez-nous une trajectoire
une planification qui nous permet de
nous organiser pour former des jeunes
pour investir dans les entreprises pour
le cas échéant innover sur des sur des
nouvelles technologies par rapport à des
nouveaux enjeux et notamment ceux du
changement climatique et de la
performance énergétique pas de souci
donc du coup ça conforte notre analyse
aussi initiale que l'on peut faire d'une
meilleure maîtrise du meilleur
prospective à tous les niveaux le but du
jeu c'est d'arriver à visualiser la
montée en puissance qui pourrait y avoir
et comme on l'accompagne aussi
financièrement on regardera nous sans
doute là on l'a pas encore fait sur la
comptabilité un peu comment la
comptabilité publique se comporte parce
que certaines comptes à permettre
d'amortir réellement d'autres
l'amortissement n'est qu'une écriture
comptable et non pas vraiment factuel en
tant que tel ce qui est aussi une
question de fond quand on est face à un
mur d'investissement de ce type
aujourd'hui donc là il y a aussi un il
me semble aussi un vrai sujet
interrogé parce que ça semble
particulièrement important
ça fait partie des travaux qu'on a mené
avec l'économiste Maria Salvetti
question de l'amortissement
d'arrondissement
à la Banque mondiale aussi enfin qui a
vraiment une personne de référence sur
la gestion financière de l'eau à au
niveau de
nations ou de grands systèmes et donc
voilà cette question de la méthodologie
d'amortissement et ce point que
j'abordais dans mon introduction sur
cette vision bilancielle une normative
de la comptabilité de manière à avoir
aussi bien une vision technique d'une
vision financière et qu'elle soit toutes
les deux cohérentes et pas simplement
qu'on se dise bon voilà on n'a pas on
veut pas augmenter le tarif et donc on
va
arbitrairement augmenter la durée de vie
des infrastructures de 10 20 30 ans de
plus comme ça on résout notre problème
de d'amortissement donc ça c'est quand
on regarde aussi au niveau bancaire seul
la Caisse de dépôt est consignation au
travers comment c'est le dispositif des
aquaplets projettent sur ce qu'ils
appellentures sur 60 ans ce qu'il
faudrait peut-être généraliser
aujourd'hui aussi non oui moi je suis
très très
supporter des de ces aquats je trouve
que ils avaient la bonne durée de temps
il s'était avec des taux qui étaient
extrêmement abordables
sur les compare à auto que l'on a
aujourd'hui au niveau bancaire et donc
ça permettait en effet aux collectivités
et en mode d'ouvrage de manière générale
de l'intervenir sur un temps long
juste sur rue une génération ou un bout
de génération le poids d'une dette
sur des infrastructures qui sont
coûteuses en effet
puisqu'on est dans le budget
d'investissement et est-ce que de votre
côté au niveau des professionnels de
l'eau vous avez senti enfin vous avez
des investissements lycée ou plutôt en
Denty pourquoi je vous pose la question
on dit qu'avec le fait que la délégation
haut passe dans certaines collectivités
certains syndicats dépensent un peu leur
trésor de guerre de manière assez rapide
ne sachant pas à quoi s'attendre par la
suite et on dit qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
se lancent dans des travaux qui ne qui
n'avaient pas fait auparavant est-ce que
vous sentez cet effet là de dépenses un
peu conjoncturelle et est-ce que vous
attendez par la suite à une sorte de
d'effet plateau en disant que ce qui a
été dépensé là ne le sera plus par la
suite le temps que les collectivités
digèrent entre guillemets cette nouvelle
compétence
alors nous nous n'avons pas observé une
accélération
significative de l'activité économique
nous sommes nos entreprises
alors c'est vrai que on sort d'une
période un peu compliquée avec le covid
qui est venu perturber l'activité en
2020 avec une phase de rattrapage après
le covid qui a qui ce qui s'est faite
mais
indépendamment de ces de ces phénomènes
plus liés donc à la pandémie on n'a pas
de on n'a pas cet effet que vous
mentionnez dû au transfert de
compétences là où on a vu une véritable
surchauffe et qui nous a vraiment fait
que moi m'interpelle en tant que
président de cette union en industrie
c'était
lors de la première directive européenne
sur les eaux résidus
ou la France avait été le sous le coup
d'une condamnation pour non respect des
zones sensibles c'était dans les années
2000 et là donc puisque tu avais la
pression de Bruxelles sur le sur l'état
et sur les ministères on a dû rattraper
dans un temps court
cette
non-application de de la directive
européenne sur les zones sur les zones
sensibles ou sur des zones sensibles qui
avaient été considérées non sensible et
ça avait créé une surchauffe de 2
milliards d'euros d'activités 2
milliards d'euros peu d'activités pour
nous c'est significatif puisque on est
sur à peu près sur des chiffres autour
de 6 milliards
en global sur la partie petit cycle et
donc
deux milliards d'euros oui c'était très
compliqué à gérer et là on a eu un effet
un effet surchauffe et un effet derrière
un peu dépression après après cette
surchauffe et ça se voit sur tous les
chiffres qui sont publiés par par les
agences de l'eau et par la direction de
l'eau et de la biodiversité on retrouve
cette beaux investissement où on voit
clairement ce seuil des 2 milliards on
n'est pas du tout dans ce genre de
phénomènes aujourd'hui
et je m'attends pas un plateau parce que
comme on a commencé à le partager ici
chaque décennie on a notre patrimoine
qui vieillit on est sur des taux de
renouvellement du patrimoine qui sont de
l'ordre de 0,5% par an
alors que il faudrait qu'il soit
largement supérieur à 1% ou à 2 % enfin
c'est vous-même voir des infrastructures
qui durent un siècle ça paraît pas enfin
vous dit parler tout à l'heure de 40 50
60 ans vous même pas d'un siècle un
siècle ça serait important
50 ans c'est 2% et on est à
0,5%. et on est à 0,5% depuis plus de
plus de 15 ans
et donc nous on appelle ça la dette
grise
et c'est pour ça quand on étudie l'étude
de 2017 et étude de 2022 on a aussi un
besoin en renouvellement qui a augmenté
parce que ça fait cinq ans qu'on est
toujours à 0,5% et pas à 2%
. donc on a un passif de renouvellement
des linéaires de canalisation des
certaines usines qui sont pas qui sur
lequel on n'a pas fait l'investissement
nécessaire donc je m'attends pas un
plateau pour répondre à votre question
monsieur vous avez un comparatif
européen à ce niveau là sur l'état des
réseaux
il y a des comparatifs européens
ça dépend ça dépend on a
vous savez
je pense que on peut on peut se comparer
différents pays toujours trouver des
pays qui sont moins bien ludiques les
nôtres et puis d'autres qui avancent
différemment et ça dépend si on regarde
l'Europe du Nord l'Allemagne l'Italie
l'Espagne la Grèce c'est pas tout fait
la même chose ou le Royaume-Uni qui a
quitté l'Europe mais qui est aussi notre
point de référence sur lequel on
pourrait avoir et sur lesquels on a des
politiques qui parfois sont beaucoup
plus
directives sur lequel on a des
régulateurs qui sont beaucoup plus à
dire qu'en plus les mains sur le guidon
pour parler assez simplement
c'est-à-dire un régulateur qui va dire
bon voilà moi je veux atteindre cet
objectif je vous donne tant de temps
pour atteindre cet objectif et si
l'objectif est pas atteint il y a une
pénalité qui est significative
on retrouve pas de ça en France si vous
permet de la question de contrat de
contrats d'objectifs partagés peut
rejoindre un moment donné un
accompagnement de la montée en puissance
des politiques de conditionnalités
on a notre rapport au dernier rapport de
on a fait une étude rétrospective sur
les fuites dans les canalisations
vous en parlez tout à l'heure ce
Président on dit un milliard de mètres
cubes de fuite ça paraît énorme c'est
énorme en effet
surtout quand on a moins de ressources
en eau quand on a beaucoup d'eau c'est
on est à 20% on est à 20% mais on est à
20% avec avec des nappes phréatiques à
qui baisse avec des débits de rivière
qui baisse aussi et donc notre capacité
à tolérer la fuite elle est à elle est à
moins importante
vous vous rappelez certainement qu'il y
a 10 ans il y a eu un décret fuite
[Musique]
2012-2012 degrés
d'ouvrage pour engager des plans
d'action et faire des choses
le décriffuite était assorti
d'une
action qui était le doublement de la
redevance
si pompage si prélèvement si les actions
étaient pas menées à bien
on a trouvé aucun document dans les
publications des agences de l'État
sur où est-ce qu'on en est
voilà donc on a donc on a des textes
exactement
problème c'est qu'avec le fondant les
agences
on parle non mais ils ont pas alors ça
appliquer ce cette augmentation parce
que sinon ça reparti dans les caisses de
l'État donc c'est aussi la raison alors
c'est une des raisons c'est une des
raisons mais en tout cas la question
fondamentale que nous on se pose en tant
qu'acteur économique en disant ok il y a
un décret fuites il y a il y a 20% de
fuite dans les réseaux il y a un texte
de loi décret qui sort qui donne voilà
des conditions d'applications il y a un
niveau de pénalité qui est pas très
douloureux comparé à ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans d'autres pays donc il va
se passer quelque chose non il se passe
rien malheureusement ça change rien à
l'arrivée il se passe en tendance rien
quand on regarde le niveau d'activité le
niveau le taux de renouvellement des
réseaux etc ça ne change pas ça fait pas
bouger l'aiguille en tout cas n'est pas
passé de 0,5 à 0,6% on n'est pas passé
de voilà c'est on voit pas on voit pas
bouger
le niveau d'investissement et donc en
effet ça s'appelle une question vous
dites en effet il y a certaines
décisions budgétaires
de ponction
dans les caisses de l'agence de
ressources qui auraient pu être
utilisées pour ça qui va clairement pas
dans le bon sens on est d'accord enfin
ça pas aidé les à résoudre le problème
mais
mais en tout cas
voilà pour dire que aujourd'hui
l'application de la loi des décisions
qu'ils ont prises est une question
importante pour nous acteurs économique
de se dire voilà à partir du moment où
il y a une assemblée Masséna qui vote
des lois qui prennent des décisions
on attend nous qu'elle soit appliquée
de manière à ce qu'on puisse anticiper
et se préparer à ce changement de
trajectoire sur l'investissement et
préparer notre industrie préparer nos
employés à cette à ce changement au
niveau d'activité parce qu'on n'est pas
sur du sur un niveau régulier d'activité
une petite question sur ce sujet est-ce
que vous savez si dans les programmes
des agences de l'eau ils se sont
efforcés de relayer cette obligation sur
mon l'occurrence
pourquoi franchement tu es donc j'ai un
peu tout le monde je suis lignes de
partage des eaux et j'ai pu constater
que la comme on l'a déjà dit d'ailleurs
les programmes étaient très variables
avec avec des injonctions très variables
et parfois pas d'injonction du tout quoi
donc c'est aussi toute l'articulation
finalement dans la mise en oeuvre de la
politique de l'eau qui est pas toujours
prêt pour les raisons que tu es aussi
évoqué mais on pouvait être aussi avant
quoi avant on pouvait faire des choses
on savait déjà que les fuites ça coûtait
cher et que voilà et moi j'ai enfin je
pour ma part je n'ai jamais constaté de
véritables engagements là dessus je
voulais juste avoir votre
retour
on a vraiment posé cette question lors
de la personne on change de lecture
chercher dans tous les documents publiés
par les agences par les ministères par
les les
conseils différents ces jeux des dcgdd
etc tout ce que vous trouverez sur la
communication sur ce décret fuite qui
existe depuis 10 ans
on a trouvé qu'une seule étude faite par
le FB
une étude qui disait que il y avait les
deux tiers les maîtres d'ouvrage qui ne
savaient pas s'ils étaient conformes des
greffes
après vous
formuler il y a quand même un regardé
l'évolution du taux de performance des
réseaux qui a quand même qui s'est quand
même amélioré c'est une autre façon de
c'est une autre lecture
des mètres d'ouvrage qui ne savent pas
s'ils sont conformes à décret qui qui
est dans leur compétences coeur et alors
que on a tout le monde tout le monde est
vous le président à bon escient rappelez
que on a plus de 20% de fuite dans le
réseau et donc c'est aujourd'hui c'est
des chiffres aujourd'hui c'est pas des
chiffres d'il y a 30 ans donc même si
les rendements se sont améliorés on a
toujours un niveau de fuite qui ne me
paraît pas adapté par rapport aux enjeux
de la durée d'une ressource en eau qui a
quantitativement et qualitativement
devient un mois même
ce qui veut dire que vous réfléchissez
forcément sur la meilleure
stratégie et quel est le meilleur modèle
économique pour s'adapter à ces enjeux
donc vous avez forcément une réflexion
sur le sujet
[Musique]
parce que je veux rester dans
je reste dans
[Musique]
encore une fois notre véritable
préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est de dire
comment on fait en sorte que
l'eau ne soit pas un frein au
développement économique
de notre pays parce que parce que on est
rattrapé aussi pas le changement
climatique le vieillissement des
infrastructures un mur d'investissement
et donc il faut trouver une solution à
cette question que vous posez monsieur
le rapporteur oui c'est pas notre
Ludovic merci président très rapidement
ce que nous le temps s'amenuise
justement dans le la grille de lecture
que vient dévoquer notre rapporteur
aujourd'hui si vous aviez une
recommandation à faire à la mission Hawk
que que nous constituons ici autour de
cette table elle serait plutôt
répressive ou incitative moi je me mets
comme toujours à la place de l'élu le
calme moi je les félicite quand ils
investissent dans leur réseau parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne se voit pas il vaut
mieux qu'ils investissent dans une
voirie que dans un réseau enfin c'est
moi qui vous dit ça juste je pense
l'inverse mais voilà souvent c'est les
deux mais certains certains continuent à
faire que les voiries parce que l'argent
ne manquant voilà donc aujourd'hui si on
n'a pas cette fibre écologique ou un peu
responsable tout du moins citoyenne il y
a pas de raison de d'investir total
enfin beaucoup dans les réseaux puisque
ça ne se voit pas et nos concitoyens
tout le temps qu'il y a de l'eau
continuent à avoir de l'eau au robinet
qui est des fuites ou pas
donc là c'est comme un vrai sujet moi je
pense que l'incitation peut-être aussi
fiscale pour les communes de ceux qui
sont bonnes élèves à un moment plutôt
que d'être dans le répressif
systématique est-ce que vous auriez vous
êtes déjà réfléchi à la question
les mesures incitatives doivent être
évidemment
je vais pas dire le contraire il faut
mieux toujours travailler sur
l'intérêt à faire plutôt que subir
surtout dans la manière dans un contexte
comme on est aujourd'hui il y a il vaut
mieux réconcilier tout le monde autour
de l'intérêt général et aller vers les
mesures incitatives
la question c'est que voilà aujourd'hui
on est forcé de constater que ces
mesures incitatives elles fonctionnent
pas vraiment et ça c'est une vraie
préoccupation et donc là on est face à
une question supérieure c'est à dire
quand les mesures incitatives ne
fonctionnent pas parce que
parce que comme vous le dites vous savez
moi je peux
que je vois un élu à prendre la décision
de baisser le tarif de l'eau je dis mais
pourquoi on n'a pas un moratoire sur la
baisse du tarif de l'eau
si l'estime qu'il n'avait pas besoin
pour lui il y a forcément d'autres qui
en ont besoin et donc on est on crée une
caisse commune qui pourrait bénéficier à
d'autres
de point de vue de l'usager baissez
l'eau de 10 20 30 centimes du mètre cube
ça va pas être perceptible enfin vous
savez de perçu peut-être la première
année et oubliez la deuxième année
alors que
augmenter le tarif de l'eau c'est que
c'est super compliqué que c'est que
c'est politiquement en tout cas un
risque que beaucoup des lunes ne veulent
pas prendre
donc
il faut il faut qu'on aille à faire
bouger le mot
culturel
de manière
taux de conflictualité sur la vie de
l'eau alors sur les ordures ménagères
et donc
on continue d'observer des
baisses de tarifs même certains qui a
revendiquent avoir l'eau la moins chère
de France comme étant comme étant
quelque chose de vertueux non c'est pas
vertueux et donc il faut privilégier il
faut privilégier
faut bannir je veux dire ce type de
d'attitude qui est qui est en creux
préjudiciable à ceux qui ont besoin
d'investir et en particulier le monde
rural vous l'avez dit parce que le monde
ils ont des linéaires de canalisation
pour aller desservir quelques habitants
et moi je fais alors là je sors de mon
rôle mais en tant que citoyen je trouve
que cette notion d'égalité a dû à de
l'usager face au service public elle est
fondamentale et qu'il faut pas détruire
ça dans notre pays bon donc il faut
continuer à alimenter tout le monde en
eau potable comme
il a été décidé à la prière de le faire
et pérenniser ça et donc pour ça il y en
a qui ont besoin d'investir et il faut
leur permettre d'investir et donc il
faut privilégier les comportements
vertueux et bannir tout ce qui va dans
dans le sens inverse et si et si pour
faire bouger les lignes il faut aller
vers un système qui soit plus répressif
on peut le voir dans certains pays où ça
fonctionne aussi alors c'est pas les
mêmes mentalités c'est pas les mêmes
cultures mais ça donne des résultats il
y a des choses qui se passent réellement
au niveau de l'investissement parce que
voilà vous avez des grands syndicats de
la taille peut-être du sédif mais qui
ont une pénalité de 100 millions d'euros
parce que ils ont pas tenu les objectifs
je peux dire que l'année d'après il
renvoie leur stratégie d'investissement
pour tenir les objectifs il se passe des
choses alors on est très loin de ça dans
le modèle français j'espère qu'on aura
pas y arriver mais elles font bleu que
vous proposiez dans la lignée directe
c'est une sorte d'incitation pas pour
oui c'est ça fait partie des mesures
d'incitatives aujourd'hui l'idée du fond
bleu c'est c'est une piste c'est une
piste de réflexion se dire finalement on
est arrivé
exactement
les urgences de l'eau sont organes de
mutualisation déjà naturel on a vu
qu'ils ont été à
abîmer par ce plafond mordant qui je
l'espère sera
abrogée et définitivement
j'espère qu'on a qu'on ira jusque là
jusqu'à labrogation parce que parce que
cette notion de romance c'est vraiment
je trouve un système qui est pas du tout
vertueux pour pour rebondir sur un sur
les propos que nous avons eu avec vous
c'est à dire que on avait un système de
péréquation au niveau des agences sur
lequel une caisse sur laquelle on peut
permettre à des collectivités plus
petites de réinvestir et venir
ponctionner sur cette caisse de
mutualisation me semble pas ça et donc
on voit on a vu nous un peu la limite de
ce système là et l'exposition de ce
système avec un effet pas la garantie
que je plafond mordant
disparaissent comme j'aimerais et donc
j'ai dit si on crée un autre notre
véhicule qui permettrait de faire cette
péréquation qui serait voilà on a fait
un peu le parallèle avec les avec
le fond vert donc
piloter par les par les préfets équipés
et qui permettrait de de d'avoir
voilà
interbaccin
intercollectivité on voit que enfin
c'est
dans de manière générale en aura besoin
en tout cas d'autres véhicules que ceux
qui existent pour résoudre les problèmes
d'une part parce que les véhicules
actuellement ne permettent pas de
répondre aux sous-investissement dont
j'ai parlé précédemment dans mes propos
et
d'autre part parce que on voit pas
comment les faire les faire augmenter
aujourd'hui dans leur dans leur système
actuel
[Musique]
donc ce serait sous l'égide des préfets
dans votre idée c'est ça donc on
court-circuite c'est le cas de le dire
les agences de l'eau du coup pour le
coup alors c'est pas concourse
peu importe de nous d'autres projets qui
sont qui viennent permettre d'offrir
donc un autre levier d'investissement
et en tout cas voilà l'idée c'est de se
dire il faut compléter et à
et finalement le constat que l'on fait
encore une fois c'est dire on est à ce
sous investissements ce
sous-investissement risque de nous
amener vers une surchauffe cette
surchauffe elle va toucher la maîtrise
d'ouvrage la maîtrise d'oeuvre les
agences etc et donc finalement est-ce
que l'idée d'avoir une autre véhicule
qui vous permet de rattraper un peu ce
retard tout comprend aussi c'est des
grises qui nous permettrait pas de
traiter sur un cycle conjoncturel dans
un véhicule dédié sans avoir à faire
gonfler peut-être les agences de l'eau
pour rattraper ce retard de
sous-investissement c'est un peu ça
l'idée les modalités pratiques
détaillées sont pas écrites encore c'est
une proposition on va voir comment elle
est reçue par l'ensemble des parties
prenantes par rapport à ça et le but
c'est un effet de trouver dans une
concertation pour se dire comment on
répond toutes ces bonnes questions que
vous avez posées se dire voilà comment
on fait pour aider à suivre nos besoins
est-ce que l'on mérite dans une logique
d'affirmation du gouvernance par bassin
il serait mieux qu'il y ait une
mutualisation on va dire des fonds au
niveau national avec une possibilité de
revenir au niveau des bassins avec une
gouvernance sur les priorités qui sont
effectivement affectées sur lesquels on
pourrait même penser qu'ils puissent y
avoir une contractualisation
territoriale pourquoi pas avec la région
les départements sur certaines
politiques pour faire aussi un effet
levier donc moi je trouve que cette
démarche-là elle me paraît effectivement
voilà elle me paraît assez intéressante
parce que elle permet de renforcer ce
que j'appelle moi la croisée des chemins
c'est à dire la gouvernance par bassin
et la gouvernance territoriale et ça me
semble être un aspect important pour
conduire les politiques de demain en
tout cas enfin je mets ça en réflexion
mais je pense que c'est je pense que ces
éléments importants oui
tout à fait il faut clarifier
aujourd'hui il faut essayer de tracer
des chemins qui sont un peu plus un peu
plus visible il y avait peut-être aussi
me permettait le président
sur la pollution peut-être que vous
aviez également quelques informations on
remarque à nous donner par rapport à ça
parce que là c'était aussi un sujet qui
effectivement va monter en puissance sur
les traitements les groupements les
métropolants et puis peut-être si vous
avez quelques éléments sur les
évolutions technologiques parce qu'on
parle du patrimoine et de la rénovation
du patrimoine mais est-ce qu'on arrive à
progresser avec des évolutions
technologiques qui nous permettraient de
rénover un coup peut-être un peu moins
gros avec des nouvelles approches
alors sur la question des nouvelles
pollutions les micropollution on en
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui cette semaine
beaucoup parlé des plastiques des
microplastiques qu'on retrouve partout
dans des quantités vraiment importantes
donc ça c'est une vraiment une pollution
il y a une quinzaine d'années on en
parlait pas du tout elle était pas du
tout dans les dans les textes
réglementaires elle est toujours pas
écrite en dur d'un texte réglementaire
mais on y travaille en tout cas depuis
un certain temps pour la quantifier pour
la qualifier pour essayer de comprendre
d'où elle vient
grâce au monde scientifique je vous en
parler tout à l'heure de la de la
recherche qui a fait beaucoup d'études
sur ce sur ce sujet
donc les microplastiques les polluants
persistants que ce soit les
phytosanitaires que ça soit les les
pie face dont on parle beaucoup en ce
moment ce sont des molécules qui sont
complices à traiter alors clairement
c'est pas les distributeurs d'eau c'est
pas les constructeurs d'équipements qui
sont à l'origine de ces molécules
malheureusement c'est c'est d'autres
progrès qui ont conduit à faire ces
molécules parce qu'il y avait un intérêt
à faire ça même les médicaments les
substances médicales on a des résidus
médicamenteux défendre le principe du
pollueur payeur pour faire en sorte que
ces politiques soient un peu
désaccompagner en tout cas il faudrait
une solution en tout cas ce que ce que
l'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que on a
des fédérations de collectivité qui vous
disent nous c'est pas nous payer enfin
c'est pas nous qui est un fameux on a au
support déjà beaucoup de choses et pas
vous payer donc en effet on défend le
principe on met l'idée de dire pourquoi
on applique pas le principe
pollueur-payeur le principe le principe
d'une REP sur ces micropollutions ça
permettrait peut-être de sensibiliser
certains acteurs industriels à cette
question fondamentale et c'est toujours
aussi une question de développer des
comportements vertus de se dire quand on
met sur le marché une nouvelle molécule
on se pose la question de son impact et
du coup que ça aura pour la pour la
détruire parce qu'en effet il y a
certaines molécules comme ces molécules
ils étaient Flon pour les
fleurs et donc dans les faire la
particuliers qui sont des molécules qui
sont compliquées à écrire et qui ont des
coûts de traitement qui sont bien
supérieurs à d'autres types de pollution
c'est pas Biot dégradable donc il faut
le faire par des beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus coûteux et donc si le metteur sur
le marché
était responsabilisé sur le coup à
d'élimination de cette de cette
pollution
de son produit en fin de vie ou au cours
de son utilisation peut-être que c'est
la mènerait à avoir à reconsidérer la le
développement d'une autre molécule moins
impactante et moins coûteuse en termes
d'impact environnemental économique tout
court c'est juste cette idée là parce
que c'est vrai que si on se dit
responsabilise de cette question là
lui il retiendra pas compte dans ses
arbitrages de stratégie industrielle
c'est juste du bon sens
bien nouvelle technologie peut-être
quelques mots nouvelles technologies
alors les nouvelles technologies sont
formidablement tirés par la
réglementation
parce que ce que j'ai toujours constaté
c'est que quand on se donne rendez-vous
sur des choses assez enfin les
transformations importantes on a on a on
a la chance d'avoir un pays sur lequel
il y a une connaissance scientifique
c'est encore récemment dans votre beau
pays au CNRS sur des
laboratoires de Bordeaux où on voit des
choses absolument fantastique en termes
de développement des technologies qui
arriveront dans le 10 dans 15 ans qui
sortent de la recherche fondamentale on
a un écosystème de de startup qui est
extrêmement dynamique ce qu'il faut nous
donner c'est un cap c'est à dire voilà
quel est le rendez-vous qu'est-ce qu'on
veut faire et à quel moment se donne
rendez-vous sur un modèle économique sur
lequel on est d'accord enfin qui me
semble
rationnel qui permettra à cette
recherche et à ces jeunes entreprises
innovantes 2 à de développer une
activité économique qui fasse du sens
pour la nation
[Musique]
bien mais je crois que le temps est venu
de
d'abord de vous remercier
de tous les compléments d'information
que vous avez pu me donner de vous
inviter à nous faire une contribution
écrite si comme ça on aura des
compléments peut-être de ce qu'on a pas
pu évoquer et puis voilà vous remercier
encore une fois pour
aborder notre notre mission
c'est l'objectif mais la question de la
trajectoire est un vrai sujet absolument
je partage complètement
merci pour votre écoute merci à vous